Our next speaker
will be Kiran Keshav.
Kiran is the Executive Director
of the Yale Center for Research
Computing and the Senior
Director of Research
Technologies at Yale.
Kiran joined the
staff of Yale in 2013
as ITS Director of Research
Services, and, in 2014,
he was appointed Senior
Director of Research Technology.
Before coming to
Yale, Kiran served
as Chief Technology Officer and
Vice President of Technology
at Betterment LLC
in New York City.
Prior to this, Kiran was the
Manager of the Development
Group at the Columbia University
Center for Bioinformatics.
Kiran holds an
undergraduate degree
from Queens University in
Canada and an Executive Master
of Science degree in technology
management from Columbia
University.
And he is truly our host today.
So welcome, Kiran.
[APPLAUSE]
Can you hear me?
Thanks, Steve.
Now I'm just thinking,
how am I going
to implement these things?
[INAUDIBLE] an opportunity
this is [INAUDIBLE]
how we are going to show how
open science should be done.
Exactly.
There you go.
That's right.
So on that note,
today we are actually
going to see a lot of
great presentations
on open data and
research transparency
and reproducibility across
a broad set of disciplines,
from astrophysics to
political science,
from American studies
to outcomes research.
But underpinning all
of these disciplines
is really the need
for a robust cyber
infrastructure on campuses.
And as part of that
infrastructure,
it's not just the
technology itself,
but it's also access
to skill sets on how
to use this infrastructure,
as well as the training
to keep up to speed
with the latest
and ever-changing
technology trends on campus.
The mission for the Yale
Center for Research Computing
is to build this
dynamic community
to support these data and
computationally-intensive needs
in each of these disciplines.
Today we welcome you to--
of course, the Fourth Annual
Day of Data-- but also
to the official opening
of the Yale Center
for Research Computing.
Planning for this center
started about two years ago.
And today we are officially
open for business.
As Steve had shown, if we look
at the advancements in some
of these scientific
techniques-- so, for example,
the ability to map the
structure of the Zika virus with
cryo-electron microscopy, or
the ability to create these 3D
models of ancient Egyptian
artifacts from photographs,
or if we look at the decreasing
trends in costs in sequencing
a genome-- the ability to
sequence a genome for $1,000
now versus the $100
million just 15 years ago--
the complexities surrounding the
computational needs on campus
are increasing and
advancing as well.
And so it's soon not
going to be uncommon
where we're going to
have to transfer data
at 100 gigabits per
second on campus or store
multiple petabytes of data
a day, and then archive
that data to be able to keep up
with these federal mandates--
Unfunded.
Unfunded mandates.
And so it's going to get
trickier and trickier
and trickier to keep up
with these computational
environments.
And that, to me, is why a lot
of these tier 1 institutions
have-- or are starting to
create-- these research
computing centers, and why
there is a national dialogue
at this point on how to
support researchers on campus,
and what are the skill sets
that are necessary to do so.
In the last 12
months, the YCRC has
been involved in a
variety of initiatives,
from acquiring funding
to refresh hardware
infrastructure--
the HPC computing
clusters-- with the Yale
Center for genome analysis,
to providing dedicated support
to groups like climatology,
or creating orbital
simulators with astrophysics.
But when thinking through an
example of what demonstrates
the broad suite of
services that we offer here
at the center, what came
to mind is a faculty member
who recently joined the
Department of Psychology
and how we handled
that situation.
So what we did there was we--
prior to her coming to Yale
from another institution--
we paired her with the research
support group led by Dr. Andy
Sherman and Dr. Rob Bjornson.
And they sat with
her and discussed
what's it going to take to
get your data here to Yale
and what sort of
computational environment
are you going to need
to process that data,
given that some of
it is sensitive data.
They provided the data
management infrastructure--
a storage infrastructure
and archive solution--
to house her sensitive data.
They provided her with access
to the computing cluster set up
by the systems administration
team at the Computing Center.
They've equipped
her lab with access
to the high-speed
network on campus,
which allows her to transfer
her data from her lab
to the compute resources
at a level much faster
than the standard
network on campus
They continue to
plan with her what
her next set of investments
will be on infrastructure.
And they will be
providing training
as to how to use
this infrastructure.
We host a lot of workshops
here at the center.
Since this past July
1, we've trained
over 400 people on
workshops such as scripting
with Python, R, HBC boot
camps, Amazon Web Services.
And so we continue to build
out that suite of workshops.
So of course we're involved with
everything computational here
at the Research
Computing Center,
but we can also be seen
as an entry point for some
of the other initiatives-- that
Steve had alluded to-- here
on campus, such as the
Data and E-Science Group,
the Research Data
Consultation Group--
both out of the library--
ITS Research Technology
Services in ITS.
We're a nimble group
and a small group,
but we are complemented by
OIRC Steering Committee.
Many of you who
are here today, who
have influenced and provided
insight on the direction
of some of our initiatives.
We're supported by our two
faculty co-directors who are
here--
Harlan Krumholz
and Daisuke Nagai--
who consistently
provide me with feedback
on the pain points on campus
and how we can turn those
into opportunities.
And then we've, of
course, had the support
of the Provost Office
and the medical school
through Steve Girvin
and Carolyn Slayman.
And we're grateful for that.
We've done a lot.
We know there's
plenty more to do.
Our office hours are
from 9:00 to 5:00 daily.
Dedicated support hours with
our research support groups
are posted on the website,
as are the training seminars.
We thank you for coming
to today's event.
I do hope that I get
a chance to speak
with you throughout the day
or in the coming months.
And now, as is customary of
the opening of any new center,
we call Steve Girvin
to do a ribbon cutting.
Hold it, these things
are [INAUDIBLE].
So we're happy to have
this fabulous [INAUDIBLE]
and this center to
help with research.
Oh!
[APPLAUSE]